[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
journal l'actualité locale et régionale
en 26 minutes sur tv 78 nous sommes le
mercredi 3 avril tout de suite les
titres une campagne de dépistage du
glyphosate elle a été lancée partout en
france par un collectif citoyen
l'objectif connaître le taux de cet
herbicide dans le corps dans les
yvelines une session s'est déroulée le
16 mars à évêques moins une autre est
prévue ce samedi à marie sur mauldre
nous en parlons avec nos invités
le centre-ville de maurepas et en
mutation des travaux lancés en octobre
se déroule en ce moment pour moderniser
le quartier autour de la mairie
changement du sol nouvel escalier sont
au programme de ce chantier une zone où
exercent 64 commerçants norvégien et la
suite de notre dossier sur l'union
européenne à huit semaines des élections
lieu qui octroie des fonds pour
cofinancer des projets notamment dans le
département insertion professionnelle
travaux de rénovation énergétique les
domaines sont nombreux focus dans cette
édition en plateau également tout à
l'heure le président de la société dom
historique et propose la méthode
montessori au travers d'ateliers à
domicile vous en avez sûrement entendu
parler hier dans les journaux nationaux
plus de 400 radars nouvelle génération
vont être déployés cette année en france
est large déploiement suite à la
dégradation et la destruction des
appareils depuis le début du mouvement
des gilet jaune
ces radars sont déjà en place dans une
dizaine d'endroits en france notamment
dans les yvelines exemple sur la n 194 à
saint-germain-en-laye au niveau de
l'entrée de la fête des loges
une installation était également prévue
à mantes-la-ville sur la d983 juste
avant l'entrée sur l'a13 homologué
seulement pour le moment pour contrôler
la vitesse ces nouveaux radars sont
capables de détecter le non-port de la
ceinture le téléphone au volant ou
encore de vérifier les distances de
sécurité
avant d'accueillir mes premiers invités
direction maurepas ou le centre-ville
est en plein travaux depuis le mois
d'octobre un chantier pour redynamiser
le secteur en le rendant notamment plus
modernes les détails de michael et demi
d'euros les travaux du centre-ville de
maurepas avance depuis octobre dernier
des dizaines d'ouvriers travaillent pour
redonner une nouvelle jeunesse au
quartier l'ancien seul goudronnée
laisser place à du granit et un nouvel
escalier a déjà été construit
c'est surtout de redonner de la
visibilité de commerce de proximité
parce que quand on arrive dans le
centre-ville de maurepas on s'est aperçu
qu'on avait un gros bouchon qu'avait été
construit dans les années 80 dans sa
seconde phase avec vous savez le
bâtiment du kiosque fleury qui lui a été
détruit ou le le commerce de proximité
de des fleurs a été déplacé un peu plus
loin donc de retrouver de la visibilité
mais aussi de retravailler les ambiances
les éclairages de replanter des arbres
des plantes un bref de retrouver à
centre-ville plus qualitatif plus
commerçants également au total 64
commerces de la ville sont concernés par
ces travaux ce traiteur est installé
depuis 13 ans dans le centre ville
c'était des travaux qui était nécessaire
ça c'est vrai mais bon un peu trop long
en délais c'est surtout ça nous pour le
commerce est un petit peu compliqué mais
bon autrement pour moi je sais c'est que
du positif je suppose que ça peut
qu'embellir maurepas coût total de
l'opération 1,4 million d'euros financé
en partie par la région et
saint-quentin-en-yvelines la commune
investit quant à elle 800000 euros dans
le projet ces huit cent mille euros qui
sont injectés pour l'avenir parce que là
on est vraiment sur une première phase
de restructuration du centre-ville parce
que évidemment il y aura d'autres
fassent dans les années qui viennent
parce qu'on se projette aussi à long
terme et c'est un investissement
vraiment à long terme et on en avait
bien besoin
la livraison définitive de ce centre
ville flambant neuf est programmée pour
le mois de juillet autre chantier mais
dans une ville voisine à la verrière des
travaux de mise en accessibilité ont
débuté à la gare sncf durée totale
quatre ans une première phase jusqu'en
juillet prochain concerne le bâtiment
avant de s'attaquer au quai de 2020 à
2022 sont prévues notamment la mise en
place de rampes d'accès mise aux normes
des escaliers de la signalétique
création d'un guichet adapté d'une place
de parking pour les personnes à mobilité
réduite montant de ces travaux 800000
euros et jusqu'à mi-juillet le bâtiment
voyageurs et fermé des automates de
vente ont été installés devant la gare
et des nuisances sonores nocturnes sont
également à prévoir une campagne de
dépistage du glyphosate elle se déroule
partout en france pour déceler dans
votre corps la présence de ce pesticide
dans les yvelines une session a déjà eu
lieu à et vêtements
été le 16 mars deux autres sont
programmées dans dans le département et
la prochaine c'est ce samedi à marie sur
mauldre sur ce plateau de représentants
d'associations locales qui se joignent à
cette campagne maïté deniau bonsoir vous
êtes là qu vice-présidente de ty santé
78 également marc gonin avec moi au
plateau de sport en soit vous êtes le
coprésident de la vitrine du
développement durable alors pour
commencer un petit mot chacun sur vos
associations respectives mais était
deniau et bien écoutez moi je suis là
pour présenter this santé 78 notre but
dans cette association et surtout de
donner de l'information au public
alors je lis les objectifs de
l'association sont d'informer le public
et les thérapeutes notamment sur la
nutrition
l'habitat pollution par les métaux les
produits de ménage les ondes
électromagnétiques l'environnement quand
les produits employés peuvent avoir une
influence néfaste sur la santé
les médecines alternatives sans oublier
les techniques de relaxation et les
bienfaits du sport donc ça c'est pour
autistes santé 70 du côté de
l'association de la vitrine du
développement durable quelles sont les
missions de cette association
le but de la vitrine c'est de
sensibiliser le public au développement
durable se lancer et trois axes donc on
a un local qui se trouve amarrée sur
mauldre outre permet de recevoir du
public ont fédéré par café des des
ateliers du pain des ateliers couture
ont fait pas mal d'animations le lyon
participe en soutien des associations
notamment la plaine de versailles
l'association patrimoniale de la plaine
de versailles les riveraines la môle de
relais athena 78 l'or est également donc
dit santé 78 et aussi cette opération
que l'on soutient du campagne glyphosate
au niveau national je vous le dit c'est
une campagne au niveau national qui a
été lancé par un collectif citoyen ce
mouvement se veut apolitique
pourquoi vous associez justement à cet
élan national par ce qui nous a semblé
que glyphosate avant tout est un poison
donc qui conte à killeen
car mika était annoncé comme
probablement cancérigène de par le
circuit l'on rappelle juste que c'est
leur vie si le plus utilisé au monde
absolu et en france en particulier aussi
alors voilà il nous a semblé qu'il
fallait faire pression sur les autorités
pour en effet interdire ce produit donc
la campagne glyphosate nous a semblé
quelque chose d'intéressant à ce niveau
là tout en sachant que malgré tout le
glyphosate il dit aujourd'hui comme un
pur indispensable pour une agriculture
de conservation qui est le protège le
sol pour justement on a été de gnôle
l'objectif du mali ne s'est pas d'être
contre les agriculteurs qui peuvent
avoir encore aujourd'hui des dérogations
pour utiliser le glyphosate c'est
peut-être de faire pression sur les
autorités qui autorise encore cette
utilisation
ces dérogations nous ne sommes pas du
tout contre les agriculteurs au
contraire nous essayons avec les
différentes associations de les soutenir
et surtout que dans cette affaire ils
sont les premières victimes vient
clairement donc nous aussi on essaie de
sensibiliser et donc en unissant nos
données marche on espère enfin se faire
entendre
ces dépistages du glyphosate se font
sous la forme de tests urinaires
on lèvera aucun suspense en disant que
chaque personne qui va faire ce test
aura forcément du glyphosate dans le
sang en battant venus me faut absolument
oui
au delà de la dose autorisée au niveau
de l'eau potable est justement à partir
de quel moment on est en danger quand on
a dû du glyphosate à partir de quel taux
on est en danger pour sa santé je pense
qu'on ne peut pas annoncer un chiffre
parce que vous savez on a tellement
d'autres pole man d'autres actifs
néfaste pour notre organisme que c'est
l'ensemble de tout ça qui fait que la
dose fait un effet cocktail
le dépistage est long ça dure toute la
journée à 97 2 heures s'annonce et nous
sommes d'accord à partir de 6h30 du
matin jusqu'à 8h30 du matin il
puis il y à pas il ya possibilité de
porter plainte pour pouvoir alors il ya
des huissiers qui sont les ans pour
vérifier que les choses se passent tout
à fait normalement c'est déposer plainte
contre les fabricants de pesticides
ricin et ceux qui déploient les
échantillons sont ensuite envoyés en
allemagne c'est ça pour un point
d'hanovre en allemagne pensent que c'est
moins cher qu'en france
alors pour la première session qui s'est
déroulée donc c'était le 16 mars dernier
wagon il y avait 60 personnes qui ont
participé ce que c'est un sujet qui sans
fin qui inquiète pardon qui préoccupent
les yvelinois vous avez l'impression que
c'est un sujet qui inquiète mais a été
bien moi je les ai vus après coup parce
que la première campagne je n'ai pas été
informé ce qui prouve qu'on a encore
beaucoup de travail à faire pour
sensibiliser tout le monde dans le
département et une inertie de nous
donner la parole parce que peut-être on
sera mieux entendu j'ai été mise au
courant là en fait n'ayant pas connu
cette première j'ai pensé qu'il fallait
remonter de l'information et j'ai
conseillé aux personnes de s'adresser
directement à la vitrine du
développement durable ce qui s'est fait
pour cette deuxième campagne
donc on a déjà roulera donc samedi son
président juste pour rappeler un peu
l'actualité que dernièrement les députés
ont rejeté l'inscription dans la loi de
la fin de l'utilisation du glyphosate
emmanuel macron on s'était fixé un
objectif de trois ans il ya quand même
des pas qui ont été faits depuis le 1er
janvier
l'interdiction à la vente et
l'interdiction d'utilisation pour le
grand public on peut rappeler aussi les
deux procès perdus par monsanto qui est
le producteur du produit du round up qui
est à base de glyphosate est ce qu'on a
vous avez quand même l'impression que
les mentalités évoluent sur le sujet qui
a des pas qui sont fesses oui évidemment
une prise de conscience ceci dit le
glyphosate n'est pas du seul produit
le plus vendu c'est le plus mais il y en
a bien d'autres
et puis non je pense qu'il faut faire en
effet pression pour interdire ce produit
pour permettre une alternative de se
mettre à la place pour me permettre je
prêt de l'agriculture de conservation
qu'est ce qui nécessité aujourd'hui une
prochaine session ce samedi à marie sur
mauldre combien ça coûte de participer à
cette session
le dp 900 plaintes ces 90 euros c'est
les frères uniquement de des
laboratoires et quand on porte plainte
c'est 140 puisqu'on doit faire venir des
huissiers pour valider en effet les
tests et l'aca majeur à 140 euros
mais je précise qu'une autre campagne de
dépistage une autre session se déroulera
à versailles ce sera en mai maïté nous y
on arrive déjà à la fin de cet entretien
vous vouliez mettre en avant des des
rendez vous organisés partie santé 78
les téléspectateurs peuvent en tout cas
les retrouver sur le site internet
puisque votre action bledi concerne plus
globalement les perturbateurs
endocriniens voilà n'y a pas que le
glyphosate
c'était et dont on trouve je suis désolé
on arrive déjà à la fin de cet entretien
on retrouve la liste de ces rendez vous
sur le site de ty s'entretient trail qui
rompt dieu donc je vais dire le 24 mai
et 21 juin
par contre les trois conférences qui
auront lieu la saison prochaine ne sont
pas sur le site
elle ne paraîtront qu'après notre
assemblée générale on arrive déjà à la
fin de cet entretien on peut les
retrouver sur le site internet merci à
vous ma et et d'oignons et merci à vous
marque bonnart si vous étiez vous un
représentant de l'association de la
vitrine du développement durable se
chiffre à présent 1767 le nombre de
saisines reçues par le député les
délégués par dont les délégués des
yvelines du défenseur des droits en 2018
une augmentation de 9% par rapport à
2010 est ce mardi à la préfecture à
versailles ses représentants locaux du
défenseur des droits jacques toubon a
dévoilé leurs bilans ils sont onze
délégués sur le territoire répartis dans
14 lieux de permanences réparties sur
tout les yvelines et aussi en place dans
les prisons de bois d'arcy versailles
poissy et porcheville
elle est déléguée des défenseurs des
droits peuvent être saisi par toute
personne s'estimant lésée par un service
public témoin du non respect du droit à
l'enfant ou d'un adolescent victime
également de 10
élimination ou encore pour dénoncer le
comportement abusif de la part d'agents
des activités de sécurité les propos
sont accueillis par patrick jacques de
dixmude heures notre mission et surtout
de d'accompagner ses administrés qui
formule une réclamation
alors l'idée c'est surtout de de prendre
en compte les éléments que l'usagé nous
nous apporte il s'agit aussi de prendre
aussi en compte les éléments de
l'administration
il nous faut les deux sons de cloche
avant d'intervenir il faut d'abord une
démarche clés à l'ab de l'usager
concernant les interrogations qu'il a à
l'égard d'une notification
administrative à nous ensuite s'il ya
des éléments nouveaux ou des difficultés
de compréhension ou alors un
dysfonctionnement d'interroger le
service en question pour pouvoir
peut-être réexaminé à une situation liée
à des éléments nouveaux et pour
contacter un délégué du défenseur des
droits rendez vous sur le site internet
qui s'affiche
toute cette semaine nous vous proposons
des reportages sur l'union européenne en
france toutes les trois minutes
un projet est co financée par les fonds
européens c'est le cas notamment dans le
département des yvelines insertion de
personnes éloignées à l'emploi ou
travaux pour une meilleure efficacité
énergétique les axes d'intervention sont
multiples le point avec aurélie oms
cette auto école sociale permet aux
bénéficiaires de minima sociaux de
passer leur permis de conduire à tarif
réduit l' agence départementale
d'insertion activity permet quant à elle
d'accompagner et de suivre des personnes
éloignées de l'emploi des actions
financées en partie par le fsc depuis
2015 le département des yvelines est
devenu un organisme intermédiaire et
peut donc gérer le fonds social européen
un fonds dédié à l'emploi
on intervient en subventions et en appui
des différents acteurs de l'insertion
dans le département que ce soient des
acteurs privés des associations des
entreprises d'insertion où le public
là on va intervenir soit auprès d'eux
d'autorités locales comme peuvent être
les apc ou les mairies ou bien m nous
mêmes en place des actions d'insertion
toujours en faveur de l'insertion
sociale et professionnelle des yvelinois
au sein de la mission europe
huit personnes sont entièrement dédiés à
la mise en oeuvre du fonds social
européen pour la période 2015 2020 le
département des yvelines a reçu une
enveloppe de 16 millions d'euros
jusqu'à présent près de dix mille
personnes éloignées de l'emploi ont été
accompagnées à l'accès aux fonds
européens peuvent paraître complexes ça
l'est un peu et tout notre travail c'est
un travail d'accompagnement des porteurs
de projets pour pouvoir faciliter
l'accès à ces faux et leur permettre
d'être plus proches de leur public avec
le fse leur permet de lutter contre
toutes formes de discriminations sur le
marché du travail
d'autres fonds peuvent également être
mobilisées dans le département des
yvelines le feader pour le développement
rural ou encore le feder le fonds
européen de développement régional
depuis deux ans saint quentin en
yvelines fait partie des quinze
territoire iti franciliens cet outil
européen permet de mobiliser des fonds
en faveur d'une croissance innovante
lancée en 2010 est le ski cub a
bénéficié d'une subvention de 333 1659
euros donc dès qu'il ya un projet que
l'agglomération identifient comme et
pouvant être financé sur ses fonds
européen plutôt que sur les fronts de
l'agglomération elle-même ce qui est
aussi une manière dans un moment où
l'argent public se fait rare de faire
plus de choses et bien l'agglomération
de sélectionne et le présente à la
région autre exemple fin 2018 à montigny
le bretonneux près de 150 logements pu
bénéficier de fonds européens pour des
travaux de rénovation thermique sur la
rénovation thermique qui est un bon
exemple
nous avons un millier de aujourd'hui de
particuliers qui ont pu bénéficier grâce
à ces fonds européens de 2,2 faible en
matière de rénovation thermique
l'objectif aujourd'hui c'est d'aller
évidemment beaucoup plus loin sur les 5
millions d'euros alloués par l'europe à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines 30 % t/t
jusqu'à présent utilisé le sport la
france s'apprête à recevoir la coupe du
monde de football féminin compétition a
retrouvé du 7 juin au 7 juillet
et c'est officiel le stade de croissy
sur seine a été retenu par la fifa le
comité d'organisation pour accueillir
des sélections à partir du 3 juin ce
sont quatre équipes nationales qui
viendront fouler la pelouse yvelinoise
la france pour préparer le match
d'ouverture contre la corée du sud mais
aussi les causses l'afrique du sud et
les états unis triple vainqueur du
mondial et tenant du titre i du titre
croissy sur seine avait reçu pour rappel
en 2016 la russie lors de l'euro de
football masculin c'était en france
c'est une méthode qui séduit de plus en
plus les familles dans les yvelines et
les hauts-de-seine notamment mais pas
que montessori autrement dit placé
l'enfant au centre de la pédagogie est
240 établissements scolaires en france
revendiquerait montessori une méthode
qui entre également à domicile pour en
parler mohamed el baz ogi bonsoir
bonsoir vous êtes le président de la
société d'eau missouri alors c'est une
société de services à la personne qu'ils
proposent et des activités montessori à
domicile et notamment dans le
département des yvelines
juste pour commencer cet entretien
rappelons ce qu'est la méthode
montessori d'accord tout à fait donc la
méthode montessori donc c'est une
méthode qui a été fondée donc marc par
maria montessori au début du siècle
dernier donc maria montessori qui a la
première femme médecin donc en italie
donc qui a choisi très avec les enfants
et qui est devenu pédagogue
naturellement donc elle a choisi très
avec des enfants qui étaient plutôt
défavorisé pauvres orphelins
donc elle qui a la vouliez à accompagner
leur apporter une éducation l'éducation
qui passe par l'apprentissage par
l'apprentissage à part l'expérience
l'ordre par l'expérience et qui favorise
l'autonomie la bienveillance et la
confiance la confiance condo que l'on
colle en accorde à l'enfant et pourquoi
ces intérêts sont justement pour
l'enfant de dons pour y apprendre avec
cette méthode
donc pourquoi scène d'une part il
apprend naturellement ce qu'on explique
aujourd'hui donc l'enfant une tendance à
apprendre naturellement donc au travers
de cette expérience
donc aujourd'hui à cette pédagogie
montessori elle et elle est redécouverte
donc depuis une dizaine d'années en
france on en parle de plus en plus qu'on
venait d'indiquer à 240 établissements
montessori
donc pourquoi parce que les
neurosciences aujourd'hui confirme que
justement le confirment les travaux de
monter sur maria montessori notamment
les phases de développement de l'enfant
et comme quoi l'enfant a besoin
d'apprendre au travers de ses
expériences au travers de ses mains de
son corps du sensoriel du langage dont
qui s'est hissé ce qui explique
aujourd'hui de les bons résultats
obtenus à travers cette pédagogie dans
votre société propose des activités
montessori à domicile ça s'adresse à des
enfants de quel âge
donc voilà donc d'un autre social la
société donc on s'adresse aux enfants de
moins de 6 ans donc sachant que la
pédagogie s'adresse à tous les enfants
jusqu'à 18 ans manque au moins de 6 ans
pourquoi parce que les éducatrices et
éducateurs éducatif et ducati ce travail
dans la société
donc sont spécialisés sur cette tranche
d'âge donc dans les yvelines et des
hauts-de-seine donc ceux de 0 à 6 ans
donc et dans les autres départements
c'est uniquement de la tranche de 3 à 6
ans pourquoi ces tranches d'âge aussi
parce qu'il faut avoir des agréments
pour pouvoir travailler des enfants à
domicile donc agrément que nous avons
dans ces départements dans ces deux
départements
c'est quoi les du coup les types
d'activités que vous proposez donc les
types d'activités donc on parle
d'activité montessori oui mon cas des
activités qui s'appuie sur du matériel
conçu par maria montessori qui existe
toujours et qui est appliquée dans les
écoles d'une part ou bien des activités
qu'on va d'inspiration montessori qui va
concerner de vie pratique par exemple à
la maison accompagné l'enfant durant
d'autres noms pour faire des activités
ne serait-ce que de cuisine des
activités d'origami qui vont développer
de d intelligence chez l'enfant qui
passe par le sensoriel la créativité qui
va visiter l'intelligence logico
mathématique etc
on fait également des activités de
langage présente activités en immersion
linguistique soit en anglais apprendre
une langue étrangère etc te ment avec
des éducatifs qui sont natifs dossier
l'angola et apprendre une langue
étrangère sous la forme montessori ça ça
donne quoi du coup comment en fait donc
c'est qu'on parle pas de cours de
langues ou jamais de cours donc on fait
des activités avec l'enfant dans cette
langue
exclusivement et l'enfant donc acquiert
le mécanisme de cette langue comme si
l'accueil est comme si la première est
sa langue maternelle tout simplement qu'
un côté ludique tout à fait exactement
le côté ludique et donc voilà et pas de
formalité donc ça ce tout cela se fait
de manière naturelle et l'enfant s'amuse
plutôt faire et vous dirais que cette
offre elle en complément par rapport aux
écoles qu'un
voilà suit la méthode montessori au sein
d'une école où ça peut aussi s'adresser
à des enfants qui ne sont pas scolarisés
dans des voiles à des écoles montessori
ce principalement donc la société a été
fondée pour les enfants qui n'ont pas la
chance de d'aller dans une école
montessori en effet dès qu'on monte
souvent très bon résultat et là ce ne
sont pas accessibles à cause de leur
prix qu'est ce qu'ils sont et qui sont
assez élevés donc donc l avantage de
notre société c'est d'une part c'est que
grâce aux agréments donc les familles
endroits des aides ont déserté livré par
l'état donc les aides de la caf du
crédit d'impôt ce qui permet aux
familles de ne débourser que des
montants très faible on est aujourd'hui
combien ça coûte environ une heure
d'activité montée sourire devient en
moyenne en france en fonction des
revenus de la famille à 3 euros de
l'heure en moyenne et donc on peut se
faire aider par la caf va avoir des
aides de la caf et avoir aussi des
crédits d'impôts ce que veut dire
exactement et ces ados missouri qui
accompagnent les parents justement poids
pour réaliser ces démarches là un autre
projet juste pour refermer cet entretien
vous avez un projet d'école de la vie
c'est ça qui se développe dans un autre
département la seine et marne exactement
tout à fait donc en effet aujourd'hui ma
passion c'est l'éducation donc aux
joueurs ont déjà commencé par
l'éducation à la maison donc il nous
offre complémentaire à l'école est là
aujourd'hui je développe un projet
d'école en seine et marne donc une école
de la vie qu'est ce que c'est donc c'est
un lieu d'apprentissage dans lequel on
retrouve pas des classes classiques pas
de prof avec qui respecte un programme
scolaire classique où l'enfant apprend
donc au travers de son environnement que
son intérieur riche donc en riant il y
aura du matériel montessori mais surtout
à l'extérieur où on aura un cadre
naturel qui serait qui est également
riche que ce soit ou par les végétaux ou
des animaux ce qui aura également une
ferme pédagogique dans cette école là et
toutes les informations sur la société
de l'historie à retrouver sur son site
internet merci mohamed el mazouni je
vous en prie je rappelle que vous êtes
le président de cette société société
pardon domi sourit un autre concept
inédit en ile-de-france un bar vient
d'ouvrir à fontenay le fleury après
quatre mois de travaux jusque là rien de
surprenant vous me direz mais
l'établissement fait également tatoueur
et barbier un lieu original dans lequel
s'est rendu michael et demi d'euros à
première vue ce bar restaurant là rien
d'original des serveurs sont derrière le
comptoir des clients passent du bon
temps en dégustant leur boisson
et pourtant l'établissement est unique
en ile de france sa particularité les
250 mètres carrés abrite également à
barbier et un tatoueur parce qu'on
voulait quelque chose qui change
on voulait pas juste faire un bar
restaurant on s'est dit pourquoi pas
mêlé le bar restaurant avec tout ça
histoire d'avoir vraiment un lieu de vie
où on peut venir boire un verre venir
manger on peut venir se faire couper les
cheveux ou se faire tailler la barbe et
éventuellement faire un petit tatouage
ce concept hybride baptisé copains
d'abord en référence à georges brassens
a été créé par deux enfants du secteur
avec un objectif en tête développer la
ville de fontaine fleurie
un projet qui a séduit le coiffeur
barbier des lieux c'est que dans notre
jeunesse on n'avait rien pour pour bat
pour se poser tout simplement est passé
des bons moments et puis bah voilà le
projet ils n'ont présenté exactement de
cette façon c'est à dire voilà tu te
souviens quand tu étais petit qu'est ce
que tu viens ici bas la réponse c'est
quoi ça sert à rien tout simplement et
et le fait de d'allier à d'allier des
choses comme le tatouage le barber et le
bart bass a enfin en des endroits
branchés
depuis son ouverture le 21 mars le bar
tatoueur barbier attire plusieurs
dizaines de clients par jour
les plus téméraires sont même repartis
avec un petit souvenir pour un prix
compris entre 60 et 80 euros
des petites a tout cédé flash beaucoup
donc des dessins faits c'est si ce temps
les gens ont eu un coup de coeur on
laisse un moment cette adresse atypique
prévoit d'organiser dans les prochaines
semaines des diffusions de match des
petits concerts ainsi que des spectacles
toujours dans l'idée de répondre à la
devise du bar copains d'abord avant de
vous quitter saint quentin en yvelines
organise demain jeudi la deuxième
édition de son événement emploi et
formation sky emploi en piste se déroule
ce jeudi au vélodrome nationale c'est de
9h à 20h 30 des animations échanges et
rencontres avec 150 entreprises
présentes
cinq mille offres d'emploi tous secteurs
seront proposés le site sera est divisé
en cinq espaces dédiés recrutement
démonstrations ateliers ou encore
ressources l'entrée est gratuite sur
inscription et à l'occasion du sky
emploi le 7-8 journal se délocalisera
exceptionnellement au vélodrome national
on se retrouve donc demain
place pour une édition spéciale c'est la
fin de ce journal dans un instant le 7-8
débat la question posée ce soir quel
avenir pour la chasse à courre belle
soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]